is there a secret to making a video you
have to be authentic like you can't fake
a smile you have to do what you actually
enjoyed that's why when I'm not feeling
like I don't want to make videos today I
just feel like okay I won't post today
like that's fine
our tick-tock Queen at Charlie D'Amelio
spilled all sorts of tick-tock secrets
on The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon
including the super weird place she
likes to make tick-tock
I've noticed me and all my friends
always film in the bathroom what why
just because the mirror yeah it has the
best lighting like we've realized is a
bunch of my friends like we're always
like let's make a tick-tock I'll walk to
the bathroom really this is so weird
yeah well how's this for a fun fact
we've actually been inside that bathroom
where many a tick-tocks have been shots
welcome to the tick-tock bathroom most
known for the tic TOCs that we make in
here every morning evening and night
this is our bath right here this is our
goose is name is Jerry we take baths in
here sometimes I've actually never taken
a bath in there once yeah shout out to
little honey
aka chase Hudson who just so happens to
be dating charlie
honestly some fairy tale right here
that's freaking cutest
[Music]
no seriously they're precious but on a
more serious note charlie also opened up
about teaming up with UNICEF for
Internet safety day and admitted that
while yes she's super successful she
actually gets a lot of online hates
people don't like talking about the hate
they got and I know especially me I get
a lot I'd rather use the platform that I
have now to talk and raise awareness
because yeah it hurts when I'm getting
it like from me but it hurts the same
when I was like in school and someone
would comment like oh you're ugly under
my like Instagram pose and I like what
40 followers it hurts the same so I just
feel like it's very very important
raising awareness about that and just
showing everyone like it's okay to not
be okay like you just have to know that
these people preach but also this is
something chase talk to us about to
which I started getting a lot of sense
she's like I'm quitting social media I
don't want to start I don't post any
more people are so mean to me I'm just
like Charlie this doesn't happen to a
lot of people keep posting keep going
you're gonna you're gonna do big things
in life you just can't focus on what
they have to say and like was yesterday
I mean who could hate that me and her
get it the most
well one everyone loves Charlie all the
guys are just gonna hate me because they
love Charlie all the girls are gonna
hate Charlie because they like like me I
guess but seriously let's stop with the
online hate next up for Charlie though
it looks like she's hitting the road we
have something planned for the summer
where I'm going to hopefully be able to
meet a lot of fans and people that
follow me and like maybe a tour yeah
maybe something like that
this summer very exciting that's it for
today for all the latest on Charlie
little hoodie and other tick tock stars
stick with all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krause and bye for now